i just want to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost i could just
never imagine the severity of the
situation travis scott breaks down in
tears
speaking out for the first time
following the tragedy at his astroworld
festival in houston our fans really mean
the world to me at least 50 000 fans
were there to hear rapper travis scott
when chaos in the crowd turned to panic
eight people were killed and many more
injured travis got emotional talking
about what happened on his instagram
story
i just want to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost last night
we're actually working right now
to identify the families
so we can help assist them through this
tough time
at the music festival on friday night
travis brought the show to halt more
than once
[Music]
as it became apparent something had gone
very wrong in the crowd you know i just
stopped the show and
you know help them get the help they
need you know
i could just never imagine this radiator
situation
we've been working
closely we've been working closely with
everyone to just try to get to the
bottom of this city houston hpd
fire department
you know everyone
you know help us
help us figure this out travis ended his
message with a call to action and a
promise
if you have any information
you know please just contact your local
authorities
everybody continue to just keep your
prayers i'm gonna do everything i can to
keep you guys updated and
just keep you guys
informed on what's going on
love you all
what the event promoters had established
for uh for the event they did have a
medical component they did have some
transport units
but uh
of course they were they were quickly
overwhelmed over 300
patients were treated at the field
hospital that was out that was set up
out here at this location that's houston
fire chief speaking friday night
announcing the start of what's expected
to be an enormous investigation
authorities say this is now a criminal
investigation involving both the
narcotics and the homicide divisions
with the mayor adding that houston has
never experienced anything of this
magnitude
[Music]
in the aftermath some controversies have
resurfaced the singer's events have
previously been criticized for being
dangerous even leading to run-ins with a
law
you know raging and you know
having fun and expressing good feelings
is something that i plan on just like
doing and spreading across the globe in
2015 travis pled guilty to reckless
conduct charges after he was accused of
starting a stampede at lollapalooza i
always wanted to make it feel like it
was the wwf
and in 2018 travis plead guilty to
disorderly conduct nine months after
allegedly inciting a riot at a show in
arkansas authorities at the time said
travis encouraged people to bypass
security and rush the stage
i will tell you one of the narratives
was that some individual was injecting
other people with drugs
that's houston's police chief speaking
to the media on saturday commenting on
speculation that drugs were a
contributing factor
we do have a report of a security
officer and he felt a prick in his neck
and the medical staff did notice a prick
that was similar to
a prick that you would get if somebody's
trying to inject that is one
part of it
you